you spend all day being the perfect boss
and the perfect mom and the perfect wife
but sometimes sometimes you just got to
be a little bad oh shoot
guys I gotta go finish some reports for
work you need something sweet and salty
just like you honey are you eating
something no gee I'm doing work reports
mommy Oh your little midnight snack is
nobody's business
introducing new snacks from frito-lay
utilizing a patented silencing
technology previously only available to
secretly American funded death squads in
El Salvador new snacks that you hide the
shame eating you do to fill the void
left by such things as your parents your
dad your mom both your parents your
bottomless sad love life you're less
than great hair and all magazines
[Music]
not only are the bag silent so are the
chips Susan you left in the middle of
the meeting is everything okay
yep just silently pooping if a chip
falls in your stomach and there's no one
there to hear it
are you really sad new snacks when
you're trying to feed a hunger you can't
let anyone know about because you're
humiliated by basic human desires from
the makers of shame spirals and Los
Angeles
[Music]